this episode is brought to you by
curiositystream get free access to
nebula the streaming service built by
all your favorite youtubers when you
sign up for curiosity stream at the link
below
[Music]
here's a history question what year was
the united states postal service founded
i'll give you a hint it's probably older
than you think
need another hint the first postmaster
general was a man named benjamin
franklin
while i'm sure that helps you narrow
down the time frame pretty significantly
you might still be surprised to learn
that the postal service was created
almost a full year before the united
states even became a country
over the next two and a half centuries
the u.s postal service performed the
critical task of making the many
separate states feel like a connected
whole
delivering mail across the country to
cities and rural areas alike
it shipped newspapers for free or nearly
free providing valuable information to
citizens even in remote areas or new
settlements
over time roads created for use by the
postal service became the country's
first interstate roadways
in more recent decades the post office
has delivered hundreds of millions of
essential prescriptions every year for
people all over the country
delivering a whopping 1.2 billion
prescriptions in 2019
over its long existence the united
states postal service has existed only
to improve the lives of all americans
and it succeeded
with such a stellar track record it
seems strange that the usps is drawing
so much negative attention today
in this episode we're going to discuss
some common misconceptions about the
postal service and why it's such a
critical part of american infrastructure
let's start with a little background on
the current drama surrounding the postal
service
the usps is fairly unique among
government agencies
while operated under the executive
branch of the us government the post
office is actually an independent agency
that raises its own funding
its stated purpose is to serve all
americans regardless of geography at a
uniform price and quality
the postal service is an inherently
non-partisan operation
and is one of a very small number of
government agencies explicitly
authorized by the us constitution
the reason for all the heated discussion
today is some misconceptions regarding
the practice of voting by mail
and the installment of a postmaster
general who is blatantly undermining the
effectiveness of the postal service
the situation is rapidly evolving and
will no doubt be very different by the
time this video goes live
but here are the basic facts on june
15th 2020
a man named louis de joy was appointed
as postmaster general
a rabid partisan operative and campaign
mega donor dejoy
immediately began his work of disrupting
the effectiveness of the postal service
he scrapped employee overtime shuffled
around or simply removed post office
leadership
and most alarmingly has ordered the
removal of mail sorting machines and
drop boxes around the country
this would have been bad enough in a
normal year but right now what dejoy is
doing should be considered criminal
2020 is not only both a census year and
an election year
it's also marked by a pandemic that
demands people stay out of densely
populated areas like polling stations
by slowing down the sorting distributing
and receiving of mail dejoy is
attempting to make it impossible to
handle what's expected to be a
record-breaking volume of mailed ballots
this deliberate mismanagement of the
postal service is an obvious attempt to
skew the election odds towards a certain
outcome
but it's also an attack on one of the
most fundamental services in the country
luckily there's been some serious
bipartisan pushback on this ludicrous
attempt at voter suppression
including citizens showing up to protest
at dejoy's home that's a good sign
but as with anything certain groups news
networks and individuals will attempt to
spin the assault on the post office as
positive change
the only way the public will consent to
the dismantling of the usps
is if they're force-fed bad information
and accept it as fact
so let's take a look at some of these
false claims first and foremost is the
supposed threat of voter fraud
the idea that someone could request a
ballot in someone else's name
or the ballots could be forged or any
number of other unlikely scenarios
it takes very little effort to disprove
this fear-mongering
according to an online database of
election fraud cases over the past 20
years
there have only been 143 convictions
involving mailed in ballots
that's eight cases per year across the
entire nation
would you like to see what that looks
like as a percentage 0.00
of all votes cast no voting system is
perfect
including in-person voting which has its
own cases of fraud but
as with mail-in voting it's
exceptionally rare and the fact that
news networks and the president are
touting election fraud as a major
problem is not only blatantly false
it should also raise red flags that
certain groups are ramping up to cast
doubt on the results of the coming
presidential election
to put the risk of mail-in ballot fraud
in perspective you have a greater chance
of getting struck by lightning than we
have of witnessing a single case of
voter fraud
voter fraud in any form is exceedingly
rare and anyone who tries to tell you
otherwise is not acting in good faith
next there's the complaint that the
postal service is a government-run
operation and is therefore slow
mismanaged and in debt
this is wrong on a number of counts
first as we mentioned earlier in the
video
the usps is an independent agency which
raises its own funds
it's not the bureaucratic mess free
market enthusiasts would have you
believe
the fact that you can send a letter from
anywhere in the u.s and have it
delivered anywhere else in the country
no matter how remote
in just a few days is pretty remarkable
fedex and ups can't do that
in fact they often hand off their mail
to the us postal service for final
delivery to remote or hard to reach
areas because they can't or won't do it
themselves
the postal service will regarding their
financial trouble
it all traces back to a piece of 2006
legislation that went largely unnoticed
back then
it was called the postal accountability
and enhancement act and it placed highly
unusual and crippling restrictions on
the post office
for example even though the usps already
had good healthcare and retirement plans
this new legislation demanded they
prepay healthcare benefits to retirees
on a 50-year schedule
which started with a requirement to set
aside 5 billion dollars per year for 10
years
this was unheard of and completely
crippled the usps
they went from operating in the black
with a healthy income to posting an
annual loss of 3.8 billion dollars in
just
three years in retrospect it's clear
that the main goal of the accountability
and enhancement act was to hamstring the
postal service in the hopes of it
eventually failing and leaving a gap
that private companies could fill
the usps had been thriving and was
planning to add new electric
vehicles to their fleet when the act was
passed convenient timing
it's almost as if the corporatists in
power didn't want a public service to do
so well
people are quick to forget that the usps
was humming along nicely and doing just
fine before bipartisan legislation
attempted to destroy one of the oldest
and most successful public services in
the country
even after taking a brutal beating in
2006 the legislation accounting for 74
of its net losses to this day the usps
is still delivering mail to every single
american who
needs it another common refrain is that
private companies are more efficient
this one is so ingrained in the american
psyche that it's now considered a sort
of universal truth
just look at spacex they say elon musk
has done more for space flight than nasa
ever did
while some kudos is deserved musk is
after all the first person to needlessly
launch a car into space
these people neglect to mention or
probably simply don't realize
that private ventures like spacex exist
thanks to billions of dollars of funding
from the government
and not to knock muskites too hard they
do also tend to forget that nasa put
human beings on the moon half a century
ago
a feat that no private company has ever
replicated even with dramatically more
advanced technology
okay i think that should spark a war in
the comments now back to the post office
since the usps is technically a
government operation
even if it's actually independent people
will latch on to that old myth that it
simply can't be as efficient or
effective as private companies
we mentioned earlier that companies like
fedex and ups hand off some of their
more difficult deliveries to the postal
service
so does amazon one of the most
successful private businesses on the
planet
if the richest man on earth can't make
his company do what the poorly funded
postal service can
how can anyone claim that private
companies are better at their jobs than
their government counterparts
the truth of the matter is that
companies like fedex ups and amazon
could make these deliveries themselves
they just don't want to because they're
not profitable it takes a lot more
effort to deliver a package to hard to
reach or very rural areas and that costs
money
so while they may be good at delivering
to the suburbs they don't feel any
obligation to service the rest of the
population
the postal service guarantees equal
service to every single american because
that's their job
they don't exist to turn a massive
profit they only exist to serve the
people of the united states
finally defenders of the ransacking of
the post office are quick to imply that
voting by mail is some radical new idea
that will lead to unforeseen
consequences
here's the thing americans have been
voting by mail since the civil war
soldiers received ballots by mail and
sent them back by mail
that was over 150 years ago voting by
mail is not a new idea
over the past century and a half the
process has gotten safer and more
organized today we have tens of millions
of americans receiving their ballot in
the mail instead of at a polling station
we have citizens all over the world
making their voices heard by mail-in
ballots
including military personnel and
citizens working or studying overseas
five states already conduct all of their
voting by mail those states are colorado
hawaii oregon
washington and utah with california and
others hoping to join this year because
of the threat posed by the coronavirus
as we saw earlier the rate of voter
fraud is miniscule and not restricted to
mail-in voting
there is zero evidence that there has
ever been or ever will be widespread
voter fraud
the systems we have in place do a good
job preventing it and they will only get
better as we learn from the emergency
situation caused by the pandemic
but regardless of efficacy people need
to understand that this is not a
partisan issue
officials from all points of the
political spectrum are calling for
better access to male and voting
and it's not hard to see why when our
country is in the throes of a deadly
pandemic
and the medical community is telling us
we need to stay inside and keep our
distance from other people
does it seem wise to cram hundreds of
bodies into polling stations
many of which are staffed by elderly and
immunocompromised individuals
of course not that would be a disaster
current projections expect a three-fold
increase in voting by mail over the 2016
election
and really it should be much more than
that every single person in america
should have the opportunity to vote by
mail in a situation like this
we should not have to choose between our
right to vote and our health
this is what makes the dismantling of
the us postal service so unconscionable
in a year when we expect drastically
higher mail and ballot volume
removing the capability to process those
ballots in time for the election is
irresponsible and downright un-american
voting is a right and if we can't safely
go to the polls
we need to be able to vote in another
way voting by mail has been around for a
century and a half
the postal service is amazing at its job
and is committed to serving each
american equally
the verdict is clear the united states
postal service is
essential and with their help we can
give every american the right to vote
safely
if you've watched my last few videos
you'll notice that youtube has been
demonetizing a lot of them
that's why some of my creator friends
and i teamed up to build nebula a
streaming platform built by and for
youtubers like me
so we don't have to worry about
demonetization since nebula is all about
creating thoughtful content we've
partnered with curiositystream
an established streaming platform with a
solid track record of caring about great
educational content and the financial
security of those who produce it
curiosity stream is an online streaming
service with thousands of non-fiction
titles from some of the best filmmakers
in the game
you can find tons of great episodes like
coronavirus psychology of a pandemic
which is a fantastic watch if you
enjoyed this week's video
as educational creators ourselves we
love curiosity stream
so we've worked out a deal where if you
sign up for curiosity stream at the link
below you'll also get access to nebula
100 free
for a limited time curiosity stream is
offering 26 off their annual plan
that's less than 15 bucks a year for
both curiosity stream and nebula
which in my humble opinion is a pretty
great deal since we're all stuck inside
anyway why not spend some time watching
fascinating documentaries on
curiositystream
or check out the original content from
all your favorite creators on nebula
there really is something for everyone
and by signing up at the link below
you're helping us produce more content
without the fear of demonetization
give curiosity stream a shot and get
free access to nebula when you sign up
using the link below
it really does help support my channel
and educational creators all across
youtube
if you enjoyed this video and you'd like
to see more like it consider subscribing
to stay up to date with my latest
episodes if you hated it go ahead and
drop a thumbs down
you can check out my previous episodes
by clicking the links on your screen
thanks for watching
and i'll see you next week
you